what's up everybody welcome to the
corridor cast here with me I have Mike
Deva he is an Internet
taste maker a long time collaborative
collaborator and a good friend of ours
before we get started into the podcast
just want to thank you guys for
listening and I want to shout out to our
sponsor which is us you can go to a
corridor digital dot store pick up some
merchandise if you would like to support
this podcast which is free and always
will be
so enjoy cool hey hey how's it going Sam
it's going great Mike I'd like to give a
shout out to my sponsor Oh MailChimp and
audible you can read you can get books
read to y'all audible a MailChimp you
better send all those emails to everyone
you know
MailChimp Wow I wish is this is that
like a personal service my life sponsor
yeah man that's incredible I'll get
there soon life sponsors you know it's
it's pretty great I bring them up in
every conversation I have now it's it's
pretty sweet Oh what is a life sponsor
oh yeah I just talked about MailChimp I
email everyone I know and I tell them
hey you better sign up with mail check
not mail Kemp not mail shrimp okay chimp
okay and then people get a confused a
lot it's it causes a lot of wacky
situations sweet it's okay okay so
there's one thing one thing I've noticed
over the last year after talking with
you bunch it seems like you are
achieving your dreams in in a sense I
would say like there's two experiences
in particular that I've I've heard about
here and we've talked about a little bit
that I find very interesting you
obviously worked with the Lonely Island
guys a whole bunch recently and even
more recently than that you actually did
a segment for off the air which is that
show an Adult Swim and these are huge
huge huge projects and I just kind of
want to know like it well first off I
what let's start at the beginning here
the Lonely Island project what was that
all about
yeah so um it's like one of those
examples of like crazy
Hollywood's there
dippity that you hear about yeah where I
was basically on the way to a lunch
meeting with this producer Mike
Rosenstein and uh
and he ran into Akiva from Lonely Island
on the way to the meeting he's like I'm
gonna meet with this guy Mike diva and
uh he hadn't heard of me and so Mike
sent him a bunch of my stuff via email
he did not use MailChimp unfortunately
that was his mistake but he sent him a
bunch of my stuff and then Akiva reached
out to me and was like hey let's meet up
and I he was the one for those who don't
know he's the he's the nerdy ones the
ones he directs all their stuff you know
and yeah he's like somebody who has
really been my hero since I was like
geez like 13 I mean I was I was watching
their [ __ ] before YouTube yeah when it
was like on their website you know and
yeah and part of the reason why I'm
doing what I doing is because of those
guys so you know super surreal and I go
hang out with him and we you know get
along pretty good and he asked me to
basically creative direct and like make
all the visuals and stuff for their live
show so I ended up doing that and in
this live show of theirs this is like
their like pre-existing works like their
there's their the songs that they've
made made big on YouTube and stuff like
that yeah okay so the ones we're
familiar with like I'm on a boat like a
boss okay and I just had sex and do it
on the ground so all that stuff and I
got to really weigh in creatively and be
like okay like I want you know for threw
it on the ground it's very like it'd be
great if we can get Andy on a stool just
in the center of the stage with all
black you know around him no lights or
anything like that and then when the
drop hits
I want like you know for the energy
drink get being thrown on the ground and
want like it to come from the top and
like explode and then like every like
the lighting guy like hits all the
lights and flashes everything I got to
work with every element of the team
including the lighting and stuff which
was really fun cuz I've never done
anything like that before
yeah and I kind of lied to them and told
them that I had done live visual stuff
created directed life shows it before
yeah
not that hard right no yeah this is
totally like my first time doing any of
that and so you know it was it was
really like surreal like hanging out
with them for rehearsals and going over
everything and like having them like
really listen to my input and so that's
turned into me essentially working with
Akiva more I just worked on this Netflix
show that he's producing for another
comedian Tim Robinson who's really
really really funny and so I did some
stuff for that and then I'm and I can't
really talk about it that much but I
make sense
I'm co-directing a thing with him that's
really exciting that's yeah that's real
it's like one of those things where it's
like I don't know why you're asking me
to do this cuz like you more than fine
like directing by yourself but I will
gladly go along for the ride and it's
one of those things I was telling Nico
earlier like you know we've hung out a
bunch but like still every time I'm
hanging out with them it's like that
whole like talking to a really pretty
girl you know it's like I'm like trying
really hard to be cool you know yeah
yeah trying a little too hard yeah yeah
totally and like the whole time I'm just
[ __ ] bricks still yeah that's sucks
no it's awesome but yeah it's been
really fun man um very very cool ride
yeah so you know a lot of the stuff that
I'm doing now is just to make like 13
year old me happy I feel like that's
been a lot of my career is like I'm
working with a lot of the people that I
grew up loving you know like it's it's
pretty pretty funny yeah it's crazy I
mean yeah I feel like in in a sense like
if you were gonna kind of like draw a
line where you have made it you know
like like haven't made it and then
making it it's like I feel like for me
just as an observer it seems like you're
kind of crossing into that threshold
finally and hitting your stride with
like that creative community that a help
I hope so that seems that that way
because whoa okay so like um obviously
you've been on YouTube we've been we've
made YouTube videos together yeah and
you know you've been on YouTube a lot
and now all this stuff we're talking
about right now
isn't isn't YouTube and so like what's
what has your relationship with YouTube
been like you know really interesting
like I feel like yeah I have a a weird
YouTube career I'd say one of the
weirdest I know of gay that's like my
relationship with them with YouTube has
been so it's like I don't know of any
other channels that have like built
success to a degree and then like kind
of left and then like come back and like
build success again and built up a new a
new fan base and then left again yeah so
it's like this weird like it's really
[ __ ] hard to come back you know
really hard especially like we YouTube
is so I mean the internet gets more and
more unforgiving every day
I mean fan bases get more more you know
what's the word I'm looking for
they're very I guess they get scattered
they do so fat yeah and like when you
make stuff like I do where it's like my
face isn't in it I'm not necessarily
like a character it's very hard to
maintain an audience because people see
my [ __ ] and they're like oh that's cool
and then they'd move on you know I'm
gonna find out who did this you know
like very I would say like 5% of the
people who watch my [ __ ] are like oh I'm
gonna click on their Channel and
subscribe and like see what else they do
so my relationship with YouTube has been
like you know I started out just putting
random [ __ ] on they're not really really
like trying super hard to make a career
off of it but yeah do it enough stuff to
where people like you noticed me and
then I forgot who emailed who well you
see I'm on crack video I think that was
the first thing that I remember seeing
okay maybe you guys hit me up maybe I
hit you up it was eight years ago yeah
it's quite a while but you know and then
so like I did the dub some cons video
with you guys would do more collabs and
this started taking a little bit more
seriously built up a bunch of steam and
then we were on this channel called
bammo together yeah that totally Ruth
like it really [ __ ] me up I don't know
if you guys know about about bam oh bam
oh well that's what sync was on that was
the ad that's our series sync was for
yeah so we were on this channel together
and it was a [ __ ] mess it was one of
the Google roll out channels that Google
threw a bunch of money at yes and none
of them really worked except for like
Nerdist and geek and sundry that's crazy
but you know it was a sounded good on
paper I was like oh me and DeStorm power
and you know my friends corridor yeah
mystery guitar man but everyone you know
had the ability to keep their main
channels maintained while me being just
a small boy had to kind of focus on my
energy on that for a year so I lost all
the traction that I got from my previous
YouTube successes yeah I had had some
viable videos like sexy sax man and you
know I was like on the Jimmy Kimmel or
Fallon show and stuff like that like I
was getting some pretty decent traction
and then I had to like put it all aside
for a channel that failed miserably yeah
and then that kind of like I was kind of
lost and like wandering for a bit and I
was like oh I really want to do music
videos like music videos of what kind of
why I got into this industry you know
like watching the Michelle gondry and
Chris Cunningham and Spike Jonze
directors label do you know it's
incredible I still have one of those
yeah the Chris Cunningham one yeah and
so so I'm sure a lot of the people
listening to this can also I don't even
know if it's like a generational thing I
mean it's a dinosaur though at this rate
people that are like you know 25 to 30
will all remember these that are like in
to filmmaking but I have 30 to 40 I
think but you know like so I wanted to
get in music videos music videos
nowadays are kind of a [ __ ] mess as
well because there's no budgets for
anything well why why music videos
what's so special about I love music and
I love creating a visual element that
complements a great song and I love the
idea like what a what a video elevates a
song there's nothing better like if a
video can give you chills because the
song is great and the video is great
it's the best feeling you know and I've
want to give people that feeling you
know like the daniels and stuff like
that yeah like all their videos like
give me chills and like yeah when um you
know turn up for what turn down for what
yeah yeah exactly gives you chills right
when he flies through the receive
yeah just how like perfect all their
[ __ ] is it's the same and so you know I
wanted to do that but the problem of
music videos is that there's no budgets
for anything and you want to make
something really really cool you're you
know gonna spend the 20 30 thousand
budget that the label or whoever has for
the video you're gonna spend it all and
not make any money and kill yourself
doing it so I did that for a bit it was
rough and then I went back to YouTube
yeah and then I did the couple other
pretty successful videos I guess he
would say viral it's it's so funny also
cuz dirt throughout my youtube career
the idea of morality has changed you
know yeah it's like jinglun is ompletely
yeah from what it was 10 years ago it
was just any 10 years ago virality was
anyone competent with like premier
basically you know like anyway you
edited that thing oh wow that makes
sense yeah cool millions and millions of
views yeah and then we'll off those
millions of millions of views you could
live for like a year yeah I mean with
the sexy sax man video like that
literally that video paid my rent for a
year
that's incredible yeah like a year and a
half like it was I was coasting on that
[ __ ] for a while and then so then it
probably could be monetized now yeah and
then a year and a half ago I made or two
years Jesus Christ I can't remember I
made this video cuz you kid trap remix I
made another video called Japanese
Donald Trump commercial yeah I kind of
rode this uh yet you were on a streak
there I was on a streak there for a bit
so good ones I was writing a vapor wave
wave yeah yeah a little bit and you know
cuz like also before that I could I
liked the latch on the musical genres
that I actually liked that also are
starting to kind of like come up like
like dubstep yeah it was uh you know
when we made dubstep guns and stuff like
that it was pretty cool it's brand-new
yeah it was just on the up-and-up you
know like and so it was cool to kind of
like make a lot of kind of dubstep
related videos and kind of ride that way
and then dubstep memes yeah it memes and
stuff so anyways blah blah blah after
the success of like the Japanese zone
trouble commercial and stuff like that
I started getting hit up by companies
wanting commercials and stuff more
and commercials are great it's funny how
about that's that's the one yeah yeah
well yeah I mean because that went viral
but also that no you you watch it and it
does it does it definitely stands out
from your other work because it's
there's like this like level of well
it's a music video definitely you know
like I feel like that's that's kind of
what it is at its core cuz like the song
at times is even cooler than the video
and then at times the videos music you
know it's like that's kind of like what
a good music video really is it's like
they kind of go hand in hand to trade
off a little bit and it's I don't know
it's fascinating exactly I mean that's
that's kind of like that that plays into
like my whole wanting to make music
videos stuff and like but the most
recent thing I did the off the air thing
to is like I you know when I get to
actually have a hand in the music yeah
I'm the most happy because like a lot of
the times the stuff that I get offered
to new music videos for them songs nine
times out of ten aren't really great and
yeah so I end up turning them down or
whatever definitely um but it's really
fun when you get to make your own music
for it but um so yeah it's interesting
that that was like a video that really
helped my career in the commercial world
take off a little bit mm-hmm it's still
kind of like a rocky kind of path you
know and I'm really focusing a lot of my
energy on that and it's a lot of like
writing pitches and not getting picked
and blah blah blah noise you know I'm a
smaller commercial director I've only
had a couple commercials that are like
you know but um but you know after
focusing on that I kind of have left
might let my youtube channel die a
little bit as well and that's kind of a
that's kind of due to the fact that I'm
only one dude I have so much time and
also YouTube doesn't making me any money
anymore and you doesn't really make that
many people money anymore unless you're
like you know you have a team and you're
able to pump out stuff every week or
every three weeks or whatever yeah and
with the way that you guys have your
thing whole thing set up it makes you
know of course like it uh I feel like
you guys are the only ones that can
sustain creativity on YouTube and
monetize it there's like nobody else I
can think of there's literally nobody
else I can think of that's like able to
except for maybe like the raka raka yeah
able although they're all be monetized
now because of all the wacky you know
clown gore
so a lot of it is like half of it is
like me like being like alright
commercials actually make me good money
and I'm able to live off of that [ __ ]
yeah I'm able to work my weirdness into
them sometimes which is great like I did
this halo Top commercial that ended up
being top 10 ads of the year in a V yeah
which is like the highest honor a
commercial could get pretty much and
even still like after that I still
haven't gotten much more commercial work
from that it's a really rough it's a
weird world the commercial here so if
you haven't seen the halo top commercial
you should just just just head over to
his YouTube channel hopefully you've
already done that by now or if you if
you're listening to this podcast but ok
I'm ok what's it like trying to pitch
someone a commercial like that
well that's so it's so weird you know
like you are you in the room just like
is it crickets you know like so she's
like trapped I'm in this ice-cream room
forever and it's like how did that go
that was crazy because like I had to I
was really it was an ice cream
commercial and they literally approached
me and we're like hey we just we already
have commercials I tell you what Hilma
tops good we want something that just
gets the Internet's attention and
there's two ways to get the internet's
attention doing something so [ __ ]
cool and crazy that people share it
which is very expensive and very rare
yeah but you guys do it and you know it
happens right but like it's rare for a
commercial to do that like Old Spice
does it you know and there's it's also
really funny yeah the other way is do
something that is so [ __ ] weird that
people are like how is this a commercial
yeah yeah so I decided to go that way
that's the way I usually like to go
anyways cuz it's more fun for me and
with that idea I was like banging my
head against the wall because there's
already a weird ice cream commercial out
there I don't know if you guys have seen
the little baby's ice cream commercial
what the person covered in ice cream
eating ice cream out of their head no
it's okay it's incredible yeah though
it's it's another weird ice cream
commercial and that one kind of viral
like five or six years ago so I had to
compete with that so my producer brought
over a bunch of four loko we got very
drunk off the four loko and i like to
think that the logo kind of charged my
like put my brain in a weird way so is
that your like creative fuel I
yes I guess now yeah he's thought of a
story that was funny and then brought it
over and that like gave me the idea I
only had one I don't I only drank that
stuff once right and I played it during
Dungeons & Dragons and yeah we it was a
four loko D&D session and it just like
it ends up with like everyone everyone's
characters like nude like trying to
intimidate people brings out some weird
[ __ ] yeah
brings out some demons no so anyways
sorry I'm like rambling but to finish a
moot point the that was an idea where I
was like okay like they wanted us to
send it to them as a pitch and I was
like there's no way they're gonna read
this on paper mmm and like understand
the vibe of this it's just gonna sound
like a [ __ ] crazy person yeah so I
was like okay I need a [ __ ] to
actually meet with the CEO of halo top
in person and actually like talk to him
about this because there's no way I'm
gonna write this down and like get this
job so I went it was crazy ice cream
mansion insane ice cream mansion insane
ice this guy is [ __ ] crazy by the way
I could talk about Justin Wolverton like
all day he's fascinating fascinating guy
he's a lawyer that decided to make ice
cream out of nowhere he's like oh
there's no good low-fat ice cream
options and so eat like a wizard he
[ __ ] went in his kitchen just started
experimenting with ice cream and then
just made halo top and like now he's the
number one ice cream company in the
world which is [ __ ] crazy Wow I'm
also sponsored by halo top by the way
nice and anyways so I like literally had
like a text-to-speech thing for the
robot voice and like act it out the
commercial and for him and like show him
like how funny it is to hear like a
robot boys say eat the ice cream so
there's like a whole song and dance and
I'm still surprised to this day that
they let me do that wow it's pretty
pretty [ __ ] crazy so the commercial
industry has been fun but then there's
also this the side effect of that is
that YouTube becomes this drug and it's
something that I think it's love talking
to creators about it because everyone
that's created a viral video and
everyone that's had a certain amount of
success on YouTube can
like to this when you get a video that
has millions and millions of hits and
millions of comments or hundreds of
comments whatever you get this dopamine
rush yeah it's a truck it's crazy it's
insane it's insane
like you see that view counter going
Android you know like I'm a genius so
rewarding it's like the best drug in the
entire [ __ ] world and you get
addicted to it
it's like success crack works like it's
not it's not like it's not even it's not
like finishing a house kind of like
crack it's like it's like you nail one
board you you you you you you're like
we're just getting started on the house
and suddenly like yeah it's it's crazy
it's crazy it's the best feeling in the
world and and as a person who's had
several viral successes but you know
after like a certain amount of success
like that like you get it you get you
you yearn for that right yeah and like
you get when you don't have that after a
certain amount of time just like any
drug you're kind of chasing this dragon
and you feel like something's missing in
your life so while I'm working with all
these people that I like I've always
wanted to work with like Lonely Island
and Adult Swim and bah blah blah not
having the optics of like seeing that
not seeing the view count and seeing the
comment count you don't with commercials
and stuff it's a totally different kind
of success and a totally different
feeling that is in a lot of ways less
rewarding okay yeah so so here then hey
guess here's a question all right what
do you value more do you do you value
like I guess okay I did a personality
test the other day as part of a segment
and there's one question that came up
that was like it's so relevant to this
do you think it's more valuable to be
liked by many people or do you value it
do you value being powerful more [ __ ]
does being powerful okay okay like a
dark wizard like a dark wizard like no
but what I mean is like it's it's like
it's like it having the ability to
create what you want I guess so to speak
you know and very focus or being
successful or being very like you know
virally might I guess maybe that's
the clearest way of putting it but well
you're saying like I could I could spend
my brain power my energy making [ __ ]
that I know will get successful because
they're the internet follows these
certain rules and I could make memes and
become a meme page and like do dumb [ __ ]
to become successful and get those
numbers and those views is that what
you're saying yeah
rather than being creatively fulfilled
doing the art that I really want to do
yeah I mean I mean for some people I
guess it's for me it's always been a
both yeah it's always been this [ __ ]
up that's why I'm like on YouTube off
YouTube un'ytu box you know I'm addicted
to it I'm addicted to the internet I'm
addicted to that attention you know like
it's it's true like it sucks you know I
hate that
but having tasted that sweet nectar yeah
it's it's hard to go back you know yeah
it's weird like in many ways I'm you
know technically like you said like uh
finally crossing the threshold and like
living like you know technically more
successful than I've ever been but I
don't feel it
I don't feel successful because I'm not
seeing it you know what I mean yeah it's
really weird it's really trippy do you
like technically like be well off and
doing fine and from my career trajectory
is going pretty well but like because I
don't have that instant gratification of
those views in those comments and the
acceptance of strangers online yeah it's
it's I still feel that level of failure
nastazya
well it's like it's I feel like it's
it's a thing where you can't have you
just can't have both at the same time
especially nowadays like you know when
it comes to the YouTube world yeah I
think I think they're two different
categories in a way right because
because um if you if you think about I
guess I guess ultimately at the stuff
that makes stuff go viral so to speak is
is like for me it always seemed like
something that virality wasn't the
intention so to speak it was it wasn't
the thing that drove it right and so
then like you you try and be
observational about a trend like
reverse-engineer your stuff a little bit
go oh how do i how do we make this viral
again it's like you know like that that
process I don't know it like it leads to
kind of like confusing results
right because also virality is is is
also kind of this crazy fluke you know
and it's like you can't ever fully
predict it even if you have a video that
has all the hits
all this stuff yeah you know it's it's
cats and space shooting lasers because
that's all the internet is right no
conversation today with a commercial
company that talked about the internet
being cats in space and I was like mmm
dog that's like 10 years ago Hey but
yeah it's like the creeper coat so you
have but ultimately up to you have two
sides to like I think most most
filmmakers or creators right now who who
I guess really know the craft and have
that kind of skill like I'm not talking
about just like just like a one-off like
vlog I'm talking about like people who
who you know how to use a camera they
can edit they can like really execute a
vision you you have you have wrought by
reality it's a choice between virality
and creative fulfillment and right a lot
of situation right because because I
don't think that they necessarily I
don't know it's just that all year -
yeah cuz like some of like the things
I'm most proud of is the anime
self-driving cars it's amazing there's
anime self-driving cars and this other
one that we just released called the
moth which is this horrible yeah that
was great - and like I would say those
were the most creative fulfilling things
because I got to do something you've
never really fully done before focus on
it and I do it as best as I can do and
you expected those both to do better I
definitely expected anime self-driving
and this is right when you like when I
put it up you put it up and it's like
holy sorry it's like the the shitty is
feeling I would they're definitely the
most creatively fulfilling pieces I've
done in a long time
and they're the most underperforming
video so we've done it along time you
guys [ __ ] out a video like biggest
lightsaber ever or whatever and we make
a sequel to it okay I've heard Inklings
of this yeah biggest laser gun yeah I
was talking I was just joking around
about that it's like hey we should make
a sequel to the biggest laser gun okay
where - one of the naysayers of the
lightsaber video totally I'm like Nico
you should at least shoot it on a good
camera and he's like the iPhone X has a
great eye like you
oh yeah we should I know but that's kind
of like the mentality we're kind of
going into a little more right now which
is it's like alright hey we had a video
go may go viral just like let's just
take that stamp and then do it again
it's so easy and and and in a way though
it's like it's it's actually you know
we're constantly combating like you're
talking about you know creative channels
right hours you know like our our
mindset for the last few years was like
hey let's do an idea and execute it and
then move on to something new it's been
much more like frying it every time and
then it's like that's kind of that's
creative creatively fulfilling yeah but
the problem is is that then you you know
you go after those viral things you know
which ultimately fuels the success of us
as a company and like it's impossible to
like do something completely brand new
and creative every time yeah and also
have it go viral because right it's like
that's that's experimentation yeah
Ranger [ __ ] with you too yeah because
was something like the moth with
something like enemy self-driving cars
yeah you're like hey wait sick this is
what I put so much time and effort into
this I care about this so much this is
you know and like when you do put so
much of your heart and your like your
soul into this thing yeah you're like
there's no way that it can't do well
because I poured my [ __ ] soreness you
know this is a part of me and this is my
child now yeah so when it doesn't do
well you it's like even more
heartbreaking you know and uh yeah
there's that old you know the whole
thing I mean we all have known this but
like you know the it's always the thing
you care less at least about that gets
the most successful right I mean Mike
cuz you can I mean trap remix thing is
like at sitting at like 50 million views
right now and I [ __ ] that out over a
weekend yeah it's crazy that that's like
that's my most successful video but like
luckily like you know I'd say the Donald
Trump Japanese commercial is like my
like at that that's I was very happy
when that did well because that's
something that I actually feel like
shows off like my Micheel show some crap
yeah so I was like really stoked on that
but but I think it was successful as
viral to do but not as political I yeah
that's now our president yeah I kind of
[ __ ] that up a you you accidentally
were like made it you actually made them
look dope that's the thing man is I
can't show that off anymore as a calling
card
cuz it's [ __ ] weird down oh crap yeah
you see it now and you're like you're a
for chanters yeah this is dark it's
becoming and yeah like alright people
have like used screen caps from it and
[ __ ] that's so funny
dark so okay so wait so would you say
ultimately like did did it turn against
you it never it never fully turned
against me you know but yeah definitely
like there was a sub-sect of vaporwave
called fash wave which is like fascist
wave oh wow yeah you clearly peaked it
definitely like used like there's a shot
in the video of like Donald Trump seek
hailing yeah yeah yeah well like a
swastika behind em it's really quick
it's like a two second shot yeah and
they like use that as like the album
cover and stuff and it's like ooh this
this feels like oops I I made that tell
people that are not associated with this
I better MailChimp everyone I know
[Laughter]
yeah so that's you know it can get weird
yeah parodies weird parodies weird I
mean I feel like wait did anyone legit
think you were like I guess I guess like
a very adamant Donald Trump's hate okay
there's not that much hate okay the
Donald Trump supporters were too dumb to
realize that I was making fun of them
okay and the people that hate Donald
Trump that was great so because I'm just
curious like you know in this in this
day and age I hit I mean I feel like
that is very clear parody but I can
imagine it's still going over you know
some you don't over people's heads is I
did this thing with super deluxe that
was a follow-up to that I am not that
much of a political person that I never
thought that I would do any videos that
have to do with that [ __ ] cuz it's like
so it's you guys haven't eaten get it I
mean yes yeah I like that you don't want
to like it's like I don't want to get
like that mud all over now yeah
yeah and so I did this video that was
like I kind of wanted to make fun of
both candidates you know and cuz they're
both dorky in their own way
yeah well and Hillary is just kind of
this like this kind of you know fellow
kids kind of you know with her life what
we pokemons go to the polls you know
like yeah she said that I know and so I
did this video with super deluxe that
was a fake Hillary campaign ad called
Hillary Clinton mean Queen and I got
this Hillary Clinton impersonate her
that looks just like her oh yeah and I
remember those yeah and so so many
people thought that it was actually her
and so many people who are like so upset
just angry angry about that video angry
about what was I don't know they were
just like pissed off they were just like
what would they say I just like they say
you know like um talking about how
cringy it was that she would do this and
just how like you know like oh of course
Hillary would would try to appeal the
kids this way and I'm like funny blah
blah blah blah blah I'm like what a
piece of [ __ ] and like you know and then
like because at the end it said paid for
by Hillary Clinton or by the Hillary
Clinton campaign or whatever the [ __ ]
and um even people who knew that it
wasn't her still thought that it was
paid for by her which is really a
fascinating to me that's bizarre like
why would Hillary Clinton hire a
look-alike to make a video that makes
her look bad and it's funny it's like
you watch a video like that and just
just just just glance up to the YouTube
channel that it's on you know it's like
maybe that blue you do that you know I
know that's why that onion still gets
tons of people like commenting on it I'm
an onion comment to my favorite yeah you
read that uh are / ate the onion no it's
a whole subreddit on reddit devoted to
just screen caps of people believing
onion as a host thing just like these
hate fields and setting my comments yeah
yeah that's so funny yeah it's
fascinating you know somebody once said
this and um kind of stuck with me but
people are dumber than you can possibly
imagine and it's like the fact that
trumps are president kind of you know
blah blah like I mean of course not
everyone but like when you see stuff
like that you're just like wow like
people are really just do not understand
satire yeah well there's a lot
I feel like although I feel like also
the it's a very vocal minority to that
it ends up reflecting on everyone else
no isolator [ __ ] right now I don't
mean like everyone's dumb no I know but
it definitely it makes it makes a hole
it's one comment can make an entire
group of people look bad yeah so yeah
like you said welcoming already like the
people who comment on YouTube videos are
usually they have something it's like
they're always the vocal minority is
yeah it's funny you know I I don't
comment on videos nice things
I don't comment things that I you know
when I see video I like I know like
great job oh I mean do you know I don't
comment on videos yes general yeah I
feel like most people don't but it sucks
when the blade oh the people that are
dumb
that are a lot of mean oh that's funny
I'm just butthurt about me and comments
in yeah okay well yeah so uh let's see
so you did a cool segment for off the
air talk about that because uh off the
air it's very it's like the best way I
can describe it is it's an avant-garde
variety show in a way way to put it like
compilations show how would you describe
off the air it's on Adult Swim huh the
only way I can describe it is using like
[ __ ] that nobody was near this will
remember like liquid television yeah
over even over my head yeah it's it's
very like hold on I'm gonna sneeze uh no
I've raised the storm okay so it's very
um yeah it's like all the best art and
music smashed into one show and it's
very it plays out like a dream it's
edited very like there'll be a short
that's beautiful and like using a CG and
like using different techniques at
visual effects to make something
completely unique that you've never seen
before
yeah and it'll smash just something
stupid then really funny and dumb yeah
go to something scary and the whole show
has this a band flow to it that's unlike
anything else
well it's cuz almost like between
segments sometimes you don't even notice
when you're living in the next say yeah
they they deceptively hide these in a
good way that transitions between the
segments so it definitely is a flow for
sure yeah yeah it makes you feel a lot
of different things and it's it's really
great it's been one of my favorite shows
for like ten years 88 years and uh it
you know it's on Adult Swim and it's an
Adult Swim's kind of this yeah I mean
having seen like [ __ ] you know it's like
definitely that those are people I've
wanted to get my foot in the door with
since day one yeah you know and so
finally I end it by the way if you guys
haven't seen off the air you should
absolutely yeah the adults link you to
just check it out for free um yeah all
the episodes are on their YouTube
channel let's look up adults him off the
air it's every episode is a different
theme and so you know if you want to see
some amazing video art and music check
it out I think that I think a lot of
people like that like you guys this [ __ ]
might appreciate it yeah definitely I
mean there's because it's a balance of
craft and just like kookiness where it's
like yeah it's like some sometimes it is
like high level yeah I visual concepts
stuff and then then it cuts to like two
polygons like low res like animations
that are just hilarious and off-the-wall
it gets written off as a stoner show a
lot yeah you know I watched I watched an
episode yesterday is the one that your
short your segment is in that's a good
episode right it's great and I just said
there's wow man what what a great show
every single thing I was clean
clean sober yeah 2 p.m. it was fantastic
fantastic fantastic show and so I
basically David Hughes the creator of
that show you know I've been trying to
get senpai to notice me for a long time
and I sorry for saying that I'm gonna go
through all of this video and I'm gonna
delete a lot of stuff so I hope you guys
are cool with me going into the edit
jumping in deleting about half the stuff
I've been saying so far as fun really
streamlining it and so I've been trying
to get him noticed me and I I tweeted at
him and I was like hey let me do a
segment for off the air I'll give you my
firstborn child
and it's a lot but you know I'm willing
to give him my firstborn it's fine I can
always bang out another one you know and
so he was like that's cool no child
necessary I already have one
and she was like turns out that he liked
my work and he had he was aware of it
nice and then yeah we went from there
and like what was funny is that we
actually had to shoot the segment before
he was out of town when we pitched it to
him and the way that the timeline lined
up my cinematographer was going to be
out of town and a week and so we had to
just pre produce like produce it and
like make it regardless of whether it
was gonna be on the show or not so we
just had to go and do it oh well like
hope that that he has accepted the idea
and if not or it's like alright well I
guess we're just out of a lot of like
money just to make a youtube video
oh mama that's a good gamble yeah yeah
we rolled those dice yeah so so I'm kind
of curious cuz I have my own theories I
my own theories for those of you who
haven't seen it yet go check it out
if you are unable to Mike explain to us
what this your segment is about or what
happens in it so the episode is called
sound and I was trying to come up with
an idea for this and you know every the
thing that I loved about off the air is
that it goes from unique like artistic
like you know unique visuals
to something that's mildly upsetting to
something that's really cool and
something that kind of shocks you a
little bit and I wanted to hit all these
marks in the video they did so I was
trying really hard to come up with
something that hit all of those beats
yeah it's kind of like that Dan Harmon
like sad funny beautiful kind of thing
works exactly that is that and I try to
like for those you don't know like I had
a conversation with we talked about this
I told you about yeah like where Dan
Harmon was like you know everything that
we make it has to be you know it's
beautiful it's funny it's sad and it's
[ __ ] what was the other beat another
thing is beautiful funny sad and and so
yeah trying to hit all those marks blah
blah blah and then my next
neighbors baby was crying like crazy
yeah and and then I just pictured this
alien puking a baby out and slamming it
around and and the rest is history
Wow that's showbiz I don't have anything
against babies I dig baby dude your
baby's dope by the way say thanks
I would not slam that baby but you know
I so this video you know starts with
like these three alien dudes in an
another void and they're you know the
puke baby and uh picks it up and slams
it and it makes like happy baby noises
it may be love this the babies loving
the slamming but yeah yeah of setting
you know the babies stoked on it yeah
babies love slams and jam jam I bring my
little baby on a walk like I hit all the
bumps right in the stroller and he's
having a ball and he just smiles so you
know of course and I think that CG
babies are really funny inherently yeah
yeah you know first viral things vintage
memes it's like it's like oh a 90 91
yeah a vintage 91 refined mmm Oh at age
12 so anyways yeah these aliens end up
making a song out of slam and babies
around yeah and and then you know then
it turns into like that's how babies are
made
wow that's crazy I feel like I cuz I
like I saw it and instantly I was like
man like this this reminds me of like
when we were jamming out on those little
pocket operators yeah it's like little
baby samples and stuff and like
basically it feels like this is like
this is like the actual like song
version of that kind of thing yeah yeah
that's funny what was your theories had
you had a theory oh well I mean that
kind of does it because I'm like oh this
is crazy it's like it's it yeah it's the
real-life version of like those weird
little pocket operator jams we're doing
just great those things are great we
need to have a jam again yeah yeah no it
was it's you know it came out I think
pretty close to what I had in my head so
very happy when that happens
that's very rare as you know yeah as a
creator very very rare yeah means you're
getting better at it it's happened to me
like three or four times in my life out
of all the stuff that I've done I made
like three or four videos where I can
say okay this is like this came out the
way I wanted that's that's really funny
yeah most the time you're compromising
and you're like you know cutting corners
and there's no budget there's no time
you know yeah absolutely well I mean
it's like that's kind of like an
approach that I've tried to bring to a
lot of projects especially like larger
ones that are not YouTube related it's
like this idea of on one hand count the
five things that you want to walk away
with as like being good about this thing
interesting and like focus on that and
like not try and do all all the things
you know it's like you want your main
character to be like well cast or you
want them to have a cool helmet you know
like little dumb details that you're
just really into and you want to
resonate and like just helping focus
down on that process I think is is
really improved my workflow anyway
that's a good way to treat it you know
it's like the five things you want to
take away it's it's it's actually a
better analogy your house is on fire
well five things will you say but yeah
like what game yeah what can you carry
out that's that's actually that
describes the one that you said one of
you said a long time ago is really stuck
with me and it's yet every every frame
every every shot of your of your short
or whatever yeah look at it and be like
would this make a good desktop wallpaper
[Laughter]
like a Nico Nico thing yeah but that's a
high standard that's a high a standard
about that a lot
well I feel like I mean okay well see
here's the thing here's the thing like
when I see you transitioning into doing
some of the stuff with the Lonely Island
guys who are like the commercial work
that you're doing like I feel like that
actually meets that mark and when you
you know compared to your YouTube work
which like through necessity
quick-and-dirty it has to be quick and
dirty yeah you know and so and so like
that's that's why I brought this subject
up in the first place is because I let
that's when I when I say made it I'm
like I
look at him like Oh like there's a fully
executed vision like it looks like like
very or at least fewer compromises had
to be made yeah been unusual that's
awesome so so that's why I brought that
up yeah I'm coming down with something
so I hope you get a lot of really good
sniffily sounds and these microphones I
hope that that drives everyone crazy
this is gonna make people would be mad
that's okay we have a noise gate that
works or if each time you do you can
just yeah I can just no actually just
just its railing lines before I came in
here so that's unfortunate
that's important uh dia I love the
internet taste maker thing I feel like
that Jake had to write that he was just
like right we got to set the stakes here
well usually because the things we want
to fill that up with some kind of
discussion topics that are a little more
off the wall like conspiracy theory
stuff kid spirit you guys talk about
conspiracy theory well we do want our
off time but not on the podcast yet
because it's like it's very dangerous
territory I mean like we have our own
conspiracy theories but their i I think
they need a little refinement before we
can me want to give me taste of one no
no it's a bit it's a it's an it's a
gnarly one oh wow that's a gnarly one it
has a wardr seen the loose change
documentary now listen zeitgeist yeah um
let's see I guess uh let's see uh my mom
um I wrote down mean shirts trying to
start a clothing line yeah yeah I'm
starting to try to I'm doing this
clothing line called faux deep so deep F
aux deep that's cool um and it's a lot
of like I want to do a lot of like
bootleg e style shirts but make it yeah
like [ __ ] that you would see like um the
classic like sonic Obama 10 backpack
yeah you know all these third party like
janky pirated products that just someone
just managed just to get so wrong right
like Pokemon were like Pikachu's like
blue and
like that and you know and so that's
that's been that's been interesting I'm
trying to get that off the ground
finding the right fabrics so is that
what the Rick and Morty one was the
sonic and garden no no no no I did not
make that that thing was amazing and
bearable that one was like that seemed
like that was part of part of it no no I
wish I could actually I want to do
something like that I have some ideas
no there's what I'm working with this
guy teenager stepdad who you know yeah
and so we got some ideas cooking don't
want to don't want to spoil and yet but
speaking of Pikachu because you about
that detective detective how about that
trailer huh
I love it I will see like yeah me too
I'm like I think you know like I more
bad ideas need to be done well it's just
[ __ ] obscure like they're not like
hey let's just make a Pokemon movie
let's make a live-action book my movie
like no let's go most obscure Pokemon
thing we have so what is that what is
detective Pikachu from do you know you
know the audio again it's a video game
okay it's an actual like it was a video
game and I think it was like was brought
to America in a weird time somehow okay
I don't know the full story but I know
that like nobody really played it sure
and it seems like it makes a great movie
which is like one Pokemon can be
understood by humans yeah and not any
other ones um that that's a great set of
for Pope I mean like I think that's
probably the best Pokemon story because
if you don't do that what it's just like
it's just like glorified like like like
bullfighting basically or like yeah you
know dogfighting yeah what's interesting
about that the fact that like it does
kind of open some doors though
kind of open some doors to where it's
like oh wait a second all Pokemon are
speaking in a way that like makes sense
they're coherent they're cognizant
they're they're they're self-aware
they're not like just animals they're
not dogs
they're like they can talk and they can
feel and they can have emotions which
makes it kind of more [ __ ] up that
like they're slaves that are generating
a ball well I think they're all they're
voluntary slaves they for some reason
are all cool with being it a slave right
because they were cool the slave you
wouldn't have been slaves you wouldn't
have to like capture them
well like it even in like the the show
like the
the cartoon they're all like totally
cognizant and like communicating
obviously we're only with one word their
name yeah but like they clearly
understand come and obey commands you
know I don't know yeah somehow for some
reason they get back in that ball every
day time maybe it's really chill in
there maybe they got a really
environmentally universe in there yeah
or it's just like a hell void maybe
maybe they'll figure that out in the
movie it's like what's in those balls
yeah this is the the polka cast yeah
corridors polka cast oh wow keep okay
we're talking about Pokemon whatever
what's what's the what's inside of a
poké ball okay okay
it's just poke a it's just like there
are lots of fish and just positive vibes
in there
no yeah if we got to figure that out we
got to get to the bottom of this maybe
that's the conspiracy theory episode can
be about so it's real all right what's
in these balls all right man I'm really
deteriorating this podcast by the minute
[Music]
so yeah yeah I think it's interesting
though because it's kind of like shows
you I guess like that is kind of the
state of the film industry in a weird
way which is it's like kind of you have
to be doing something very very loud I
think to get any attention right now oh
yeah in that sense yeah everyone's like
it's so interesting the reaction that
that's gotten well yeah how like people
are just kind of pissed off about it and
I don't understand fully why it's more
just surreal to me to see like Pokemon
and like a real environment and Leia to
see how creepily rendered some of them
are like mr. mime yeah like does not
render the little hairs on and stuff
it's pretty incredible yeah but it's
also like kind of jarring and like it's
a little bit he's a little bit on candy
Valley and I would say so uh I know you
went to Korea for a while lately yeah
korea's dope how was that trip what was
campus yeah it's just chillin just
chillin with the fame that's sweet yeah
cruise great man i if anybody has the
opportunity to go to anywhere in Asia I
would say Korea
is the place to go it is like I mean the
Koreans are like the bad boys the bad
boys you're partially a bad boy I'm
partial bad boy oh wow but you're a bad
boy a partial good boy and yeah yeah and
so you know it's like they just know how
to have fun and party and go nuts and
there's like isn't it like some of I
think next to Finland its highest amount
of alcohol presumed per capita oh really
I'm pretty sure I saw a sigh I was
looking at up of year to go and it's
like you have Russia Finland and Korea
it's like I believe it I believe high
performers yeah you'll see like
businessmen like passed out in the
street in their own vomit oh my gosh I
like yeah like this dude like I saw this
dude laying down with his cell phone
like laying outside of his pocket and if
you did that if that happened in America
you're [ __ ] but in Korea like they're
so know like I saw a dude walk up to him
and like put his cell phone like inside
his pocket oh that's very nice it's very
nice yeah very thoughtful yeah so uh um
it's you you you are you are half Korean
and a half Swede half sweet sweet and
that's interesting and where do you get
what from my pops is Swedish okay mom's
Korean and you know it's uh they're
they're they're they're adorable gotta
say gotta go I don't know if you've seen
my parents but they're very happy and
they're very loving I think I met your
mom once yeah yeah probably
who knows yeah I think you have it's
always like it's like whenever you meet
people's parents it's like in in in LA
anyways like I feel like chances are
that it's like it's at a really crowded
party or something like that
yeah for some reason it's like somehow
that's that's the situation I met your
parents I I'm so it was probably had a
crowded party that I don't remember much
about definitely make it cool uncle yeah
yeah he makes an impression if you guys
have seen Sam's cool uncle but he's got
he's very kooky I was eccentric yeah I
would say that I'd say that yeah he's
very much an artist kind of like a
badass like yeah he just looks like a
crazy artist yeah if you saw him walking
down the street what does that guy do
yeah what is he
deal so do you still have family in
Korea yeah yeah so that's the reason was
there just visiting family and so what
well guess like you know it's it's
interesting like having a family like
that far away cuz you kind of like
forget they exist until you're there
like how close how close how media is
this family thank you I have a lot of
cousins and stuff okay and yeah I might
you know my mom's sister and stuff and
yeah it's it's really dope like
connecting with people from you know
especially people like last Mo's are ten
years ago they were like five and now
they're like you know
well like grown-ass yeah now there's
like 20 years olds and like you know
it's like a drink with them and stuff
yeah okay it's super chill that's that's
interesting yeah that's super cool yeah
Korea is a great place man I really I
really dig it yeah yeah definitely
always try and travel as much as I
possibly can
yeah I've only have only been to Japan
not Korea yet that's right but yeah
Japan's great too but Japan's
interesting there's like this really
there's this uh this loneliness and this
kind of like disconnect that everyone
has you can kind of feel it you know
like it's so like it's such a repressed
kind of culture that you kind of feel
this isolation you know wow and
everything is also very like sexual and
very like all the entertainment is like
kits and your face and like well you
know it's like like I don't if you
noticed that or not but it was all very
gear yards that yeah whereas like Korea
it's like you're walking down the street
and there's like an arcade and then you
go into the arcade you go upstairs and
there's like a place with like a cafe
with puppies and you just hang out with
puppies and drink tea Wow and then you
go the next floor upstairs and there's
like a bar where you shoot BB guns at
targets and like just like they know how
to have fun in a way that I've never
seen anywhere else in the world it's
interesting why do you think that is I
don't know it's really I think it's just
cuz Korea prides themselves as being
like entertainment you know people
that's like hey pop is such a huge thing
and stuff like that I think that Korea
like kind of they have that Arab that
you know they're like they consider
themselves like more entertainment focus
than I think Japan and China interesting
so you know there's always [ __ ] to do
and there's like everywhere you go
there's like dope [ __ ] to do yeah yeah I
mean and just
not that I am an expert on it by any
means but it it also kind of like when
you when you look at you know like Asia
great as a greater whole it's like I
feel like kind of like socially compared
to like you know western countries like
Korea overlaps just I feel like the most
with I guess you know like us culture
and stuff it's starting to yeah yeah
actually with kpop becoming much more of
like mainstream yeah in a lot of ways
like you see a lot of kpop bands and
like commercials and stuff now which is
really interesting to me and like you
know yeah yeah actually yeah you're
right it's it's it's finally like
crossing over and that's a pretty recent
thing you know but Korea definitely has
a lot of overlap in a lot of different
ways yeah hmm that's fascinating yeah do
you uh did you go to North Korea I have
been to the Demilitarized Zone but I
mean South Korea North Korea it's a very
weird place I can imagine like it's
intense man I mean I don't know how much
you guys know about the like what the
DMZ is like but like there's literally a
building where one dude from South Korea
is standing like with half his face
covered by the building and then on the
opposite end of the building there's a
dude from North Korea who are half his
face is covered by the building and
their jobs are to literally stand there
and stare at each other all [ __ ] day
Wow
and that's what they do it's so with one
eye with one eye with one eye covered
and what but they wear sunglasses they
both wear sunglasses so you can't really
get their emotions or anything like that
I do not understand why that's a thing
but like literally these [ __ ]
these military Jews are just standing
and staring at each other all day it's
really [ __ ] weird
that's so weird yeah I don't understand
like what that accomplish is I mean I
guess it's like a quick-draw thing
keeping you in check like nothing the
closest guys yeah there's like some sort
of constant sort of communication
between the two sides at all times man
that's messed up but I don't understand
well it's weird how like you can get to
that point where it's like we literally
need people staring eye to eye yeah just
mere feet away from each other the trust
level is
shattered and shaken absolutely like
like yeah I don't know yeah it's very
bizarre and they wouldn't let me wear
jeans that are that are torn at all I
have a lot of my jeans have like you
know tears in them because I'm a bad boy
yeah it was the half badness
yeah the half bad boy Korea sighs yeah
yeah just wanted to act out and go nuts
and so I had to buy new pants because
then who didn't allow you to him where
those are the DMZ doesn't like that the
like the zone because it upsets the
North Koreans I don't know why they just
don't like fashion they don't like skits
too much skin yeah and I was like it's
called fashion sweetie no but they they
actually like stare at you with
binoculars from the other side okay and
they look they all like just keep you
out
there's peeping with their papers just
looking really weird and they see one
guy with ripped jeans and the other on
the phone they're like you have to get
him out of here he's gotta go down he's
like we can't stop looking at but then
you just get black bagged and they never
heard heard from again all sorts of
crazy stories man I mean there's this
like you know is driving by like they
did this tour of the actual zone right
yeah and you get driven by this tree
stump this giant tree stump and till the
story about how I came down ill what
basically well because what happened was
like the Americans were like hey this
tree is too big it's blocking our view
it's blocking North South Korea's view
from North Korea and we need to be able
to peep at any time and oh and Kim
jong-un was like no I planted this
[ __ ] tree this is my tree and if you
cut that tree down it's an enormous
disrespect right and first of all for
him to find that tree he'd have to be
like hundreds of years old right like
it's a giant the giant [ __ ] tree yeah
yeah yeah and uh and they were like no
we're gonna we're gonna you guys got to
cut down the street like [ __ ] you you
didn't plant this tree you gotta cut
down it's too much okay they're like no
[ __ ] you were never gonna cut down this
tree and then finally they got these two
soldiers I think Americans holders to
cut down the tree and the
go there to go to cut down the tree and
then to North Koreans with axes pop out
and just murder them oh my god like with
axes there's all sorts of crazy [ __ ]
stories like are we sitting there for
like weeks
yeah because well yeah it's - there's
all sorts of crazy like I mean North
Korea just like shoots down planes for
no reason yeah and then there's like
there's like this flag battle they had
over like South Korea have this flag the
South Korean flag that was like kind of
like is visible I know it's curry right
and so North Korea is like oh [ __ ] you
we're gonna make a flag that's even
taller for our great nation and then
like then South Korea is like no [ __ ]
you
we're gonna make our flight tolerance
way though there's like even taller and
there's like no double [ __ ] you we're
gonna make the tallest flag in the world
and they used like all of their
resources meanwhile people are starving
it's like oh I was gonna eat that uses
money to you know feed your people but
instead they decided to make a bigger
flag just for this giant dick song yeah
I was gonna wear that fabric yeah I'm
cold
but I guess you can make a flag yeah
like using the actual metal and stuff
like the structure itself is just like
huge and that's still standing and it's
still standing it's it's completely
consumed for most of South Korea yeah
it's insanity really makes a difference
yeah I did not expect this podcast to go
into talking about North Korea I mean I
I hate se but I find that stuff
fascinating
yeah I mean well I mean it's it is it's
insane it's it's remember when the
[ __ ] UH the interview came out firm
in a weird drama about it was so bizarre
like people they're like actually gonna
like start a war over like Seth Rogen
yeah well do you think um do you think
people will find peace with North Korea
I guess I do you think all the stuff
that happened over the last year is
gonna go anywhere like you know like
it's it's hard to say I think that I
mean I don't think so
I think that in order for things to
change I think there's got to be
something way more radical than like Kim
Jong Il's
just deciding to be a good guy all of a
sudden and just being like oh no this
crazy life that I was born into that I
you know I mean he is the way he is
because he was born into this crazy
[ __ ] yes but he's they weren't rich
you know yeah he's born a king was born
this crazy God figure in you and you're
not just gonna like grow up in that
environment and all of a sudden get a
conscience yeah it's almost it's you're
right God is an interesting word to
apply to I it does because I was
listening to a lot of stuff about um
like you know in ancient Persia like the
Persians like around the time of like
Xerxes in that whole like biblical era
and you definitely have these yeah it's
that cult of personality thing that
people you know it rises and falls a
little bit but like it's it's not so
much that kind of central figure thing I
don't know Yakima it must completely
mess with you ya know that's gotta [ __ ]
anybody up you know in that much power
and that much control will taint anyone
I mean it's like kind of my theory about
like you I feel like if you get a
certain amount of success and fame and
money it warps you and I think that
that's impossible I mean it's part of
the human condition yeah you know and
it's it's interesting like yeah I hear
that Donald Glover is like kind of you
know like doesn't give people the time
of day and it's like yeah of course
because everybody wants him like
everybody wants a piece of you and you
you're the [ __ ] and like in mall arenas
that's gotta [ __ ] with you that's gonna
[ __ ] with your time and who you're
willing to give your time to do you
think Donald Glover do you think he goes
after uh use or virality for creative
fulfillment for sure I mean he's like
you know a true artist like you know I
I'm I'm like to back to that point I
feel like I'm kind of halfway you know I
feel like I feel like if I really truly
focused in one arena and I could have
that focus I'd succeed much more but the
fact that I'm constantly battling with
that [ __ ] where it's like oh I want to
me I want to make this cuz it's like
what I want to do it's like you know but
then it doesn't do well that I get sad
well he makes an album and then produces
a TV show and there's that great
a [ __ ] unicorn I mean he's you know
yeah cuz it's [ __ ] crazy genius yeah
exactly don't compare yourself to who
someone else is today only compare
yourself to who you were yesterday whoa
dude nice there you go to compare us to
despair Yeah right exactly
I know that's a bad example no no one
can bring him up because he's too good
at everything
yes don't count him yeah [ __ ] that dude
yeah dude it's so funny like watching
old I don't remember if you remember
Derek Comedy vaguely his old comedy
group oh yeah yeah
and they had like the spelling bee and
like a bunch of like classic classic
internet sketches and the back one like
you can make sketches on the Internet
remember that yeah right I remember when
there was like content remember there
was like unblock related on video game
related content on the internet that was
entertaining and cool that was cool
I missed that anyways um that's part of
the reason why I don't [ __ ] with YouTube
as much anymore is because like there's
nothing really that inspiring other than
you guys you know it's it's it's tough
because I think you know going back to
that whole virality versus fulfillment
thing it's being derivative is it's a
much more sure shot it's you know
success yeah and so in a way it's easier
but and also another way just over
saturates it with stuff that you either
already seen or don't want to see yeah
it's so it's yeah yeah yeah absolutely
and so anyways sorry to finish my point
I was showing my friend and this is more
testament to how things have changed
over the past like seven years
how comedy has changed how entertainment
has changed how attention spans have
changed yeah rapidly yeah you know so
much so that you can never be really an
expert in any of it yeah and I was like
my friends a fan of childish gambino and
I showed them I was like oh yeah if you
like childish gambino you should see the
old Derek comedy like sketches right and
I showed him the sketch that seven eight
years ago was the [ __ ] yeah and it's a
five minute sketch all my hands at one
of those times what we were checking the
phone and half dude it was the mo
cringy like excruciating [ __ ] and you
could we were both just like dude comedy
does not age well ah that's funny
especially YouTube comedy is not aged
well and you cannot make a comedy video
that's more that's more than like two
minutes now so I mean I guess I guess
that's the thing I so when you brought
up um you're like well if you like this
then you like that I mean you know like
what like II would you say that's
partially like a side effect of the fact
that I guess most sharing it's like
algorithmic based now where it's like
it's not it's not like person going hey
you might like this but you're used to
like basically a machine telling you
like with it cuz cuz that's that's all
the own Netflix and YouTube and Facebook
and like we're starting to it we're
almost we're almost completely in that
world now where it's it's all about like
that's an predictability and Inlet and
and a lot of virality has to do with
like the fan bases that are already
watching your [ __ ] to bump it up to a
place where it's like you're sitting
it's like less word-of-mouth
yeah exactly it's either either you have
an audience that's there every time but
the audience has to do hand-in-hand with
the algorithm right if the audience
wasn't there then how would you I see I
see I see it's I see it separately oh
you're right
well I mean sorry it's three it's you
have all audience Oh algorithm or both
audience applause algorithm yeah and and
like you know I feel like that's that's
like true for anything like if you have
an algorithm of course you're gonna it's
gonna listen to a piece or or take note
of a piece that is getting views and and
actually getting organic traction right
but at the same time you know like you
can feed the Machine like do all I must
feed the machine do you know yeah that's
what I'm saying but I think that's also
playing into that thing of you know oh
you know the whole the feeling of all we
didn't go viral or whatever right it's
you know I think it's sometimes not
necessarily just oh it's not it's not
actually a statement of quality you know
or like whether it's good or not it's
just like you know I don't know they
need at the robot that was like trying
to dish it out to everyone just was like
I don't get it
no I mean that is that is kind of the
thing you know and it's like especially
you know with the YouTube YouTube's
algorithms being violently unforgiving
yeah uh you know it's it's harder than
ever to make anything successful these
days yeah well yeah would you do you
think okay well I guess I guess that's a
question here um do you think the
algorithms like that that we're kind of
moving into do you think they help or
hurt Ultimo grace hurt for sure okay I
think that yeah I you know I'm like and
this might just be my age going but um
you know there was a time when YouTube's
front page was hand selected by people
and it was it was all interesting good
content you can go to the front page of
YouTube and see stuff that's non
algorithmic that are hand-picked by
people that that are just like hey if
you like this kind of thing here's this
kind of thing if you like cool special
effects videos here's this thing bah
blah blah blah blah and I feel like that
will always be better than an algorithm
also I mean they'll just the way that
YouTube's algorithms become its own kind
of beast I feel like YouTube broke
itself I feel like YouTube is is a is it
just flawed and and I they've even
admitted to it - yeah they admitted that
they broke it yeah um
it's really sad you know it's and
everything I feel like the Internet in
general without being - bummer is is
just getting like exponentially worse
every year and I don't think that
anybody can argue with that I think that
we can all agree that we remember a
better internet like four years ago even
well I think it's all about like I mean
as a concept it's about breaking those
positive feedback loops that you start
to create and you do it and everyone
does it in every other aspect of their
life already
but like especially I think this is the
most literal version of it it's like no
are you mean by that
okay well I hand you something and
you're like I like that and like oh you
like that well I keep handing it to you
over and over and over again and
suddenly it's just like your life just
becomes oh I only like this one thing
right you know in the world yeah and so
you know you see that with Facebook and
the way news articles are shared you see
that in YouTube with how the
where them insurance videos you know
Netflix it's like yeah only shows you
like oh well you like action movies
won't boom only action movies and I
think it's all about like you know
making sure you're conscious of those
cycles that you put yourself in in your
own everyday life like eating a
particular type of food like your diet
or like the way you kind of get exercise
or thing you know things like that and I
like you you put it's it's it's almost
like having humanity though right yeah I
guess so have it forming we that's
comfort to us and and anything outside
of that is scary
yeah I'm different exactly and it's
weird because you have these these
feedback loops I think happening online
with most people yeah like their
accounts you know they're being tracked
and flagged and tagged and and you know
I I don't I feel like hopeful hopefully
the future of that is finding a way to
like effectively break it break that
monotony up I think that what's
interesting is that like Instagram is
like one of the only things that I can
think of now that hasn't necessarily
shot itself in the foot to oblivion you
know what I mean like it hasn't [ __ ]
with the algorithm too much to where
it's just completely you can't keep up
it's unpredictable it's like it's one of
those things where it's like it makes
sense you know why you know why it's
because every single thing you're seeing
on there general generally is
something that he made an active
decision just to view yeah like you're
in its it yeah obviously you get some
sponsored posts every once in a while
basically adds but ultimately you're
you're generally seeing the people that
you chose to follow yeah and they're not
going hey uh hey by the way we're just
gonna slip these other or three random
people into your feed that you don't
know and you know it's like they're not
they haven't gotten to that stage yet
um obviously there's features to browse
etc but like I think that would be that
would be that the kind of breaking point
where Instagram is stops becoming useful
so like when it when it becomes too much
of I guess a media network and not a
social network which it will inevitably
it's weird because I feel like you I do
I think it is moving towards that of
course I mean anything on a long enough
time line turns into that right anything
yeah I mean I mean anything that's
successful enough on a long enough time
line online anymore yes this kind of you
know it starts out as Anakin and becomes
this Darth Vader wow that's intense I
mean you know everything remember when
Google was like this friendly yeah
Google they're fighting for us now
there's like an evil yeah well it's when
they took the don't be evil like phrase
out of their like their mission
statement that's when it that was on the
emergency yeah it was don't be evil and
then it's mysteriously not in there now
[Laughter]
exactly I mean it's it's inevitable but
yeah you know I don't I mean it's it's
weird cuz I I think it's it's kind of
this it's thing it's a thing where it's
I think a lot of the things people think
our bad decisions are ultimately still
done in in or with good intentions like
like most things in life
bad bad bad things happen with good
intentions sometimes yeah I do feel like
um yeah like a lot of it also is just
not understanding yeah it's it's having
too much power and not fully
understanding the thing you have power
over yeah
in order to make it look like you're
doing your job you feel the need to
change it and make it better
yeah when it was fine yeah yeah you know
hence what happened to YouTube exactly
yeah that's its I hope this isn't all
too negative I'm not I mean this I mean
I think it's it's about like you know
going in there and figuring it yeah
we're talking about it right now I'm not
a very negative overall person you know
and I don't want this podcast eternity
be like it's interesting though like
[ __ ] you dude like at least you've had
that success you know yeah and I guess I
guess my only point was like yes that's
awesome and I'm grateful for that and of
course it's like made my life way better
and and and it's made my life I mean you
know I wouldn't anywhere if it wasn't
for that success but all I'm saying is
like it like anything it's it's just
interesting how it becomes this drug and
it's interesting how that dopamine rush
is something you become addicted to and
that's why a lot of you know with this
YouTube stuff like the way it is and how
fast paced everything is you're gonna
see more more of that YouTube burnout
that you know I don't have you've read
that article oh I've seen yeah I've seen
a lot of it I may be not the one you're
talking about but I'm very familiar yeah
it happens on Twitch even more oh yeah
I'm sure cuz like Twitter means heart
which is like going out into the mines
man media mining just like grinding yeah
yeah exactly and like yeah I mean I
don't I don't understand how these
people do YouTube nowadays with like
having to release a video every day or
every other day it's like at that point
you do not have a life and it's still
viewed as something where it's like ah
you're just a [ __ ] youtuber you know
it's like [ __ ] you like it's like no
these people are working harder than you
are like you do not like you know it's
easy for people to talk [ __ ] about it
but it's like you at that point like
that's your existence and it's hard as
[ __ ] yeah well it's it's weird because
he ultimately well it's the
entertainment industry yeah it's it's
since there's no clear path to success
yeah it's just like do you do people
find it entertaining you know it's like
it's not about your message it's not
about your politics
it's not about anything it's just like
that's all that's only that's the only
thing that matters it's like yeah is it
entertaining and yeah ya know it's very
hard to figure out what is entertaining
what is funny is it what I think is
funny or is what other people think
another thing our age right interesting
getting older in this world in this in
this fast fast pace internet world you
know cuz it's as do you kind of I don't
know if you felt it or seen it but you
find yourself getting a little bit more
out of touch with certain things where
it's like and I haven't completely
gotten there but you know there's
there's that when you ate a meme and
you're like oh crap I I don't get this
mean right and that's rare that's rare
III stay up with my memes to an extent
and I thank God like there's like I
still find 90% of means names funny like
yeah especially the obscure like insane
[ __ ] they would is always surprising
when it gets big right like the moth
memes and like you know that if I can I
don't even get I was introduced to the
moth meme after we released the video
called them off oh really and then
everyone's making known references and I
I'm like oh man alone oh yes that crazy
how you named it after a meme and like
yeah yeah I made a serious film based on
me there's that crazy reinterpret let me
go home you know I argue it hurt it
that's interesting
I'd argue that it was like everyone's
like oh it's the meme you know instead
of like because you think cuz you hit it
at the tail end of the meme yeah you hit
it you hit it post the memes I went the
door I let the door hit my ass yep yep
it's that it's that half life right I
mean it's that [ __ ] it's crazy you
know it's like you and it's impossible
to make a video related to a meme now
it's like it's it's unless you can bang
it out in a day unless yeah it's like
yeah one day 24 hours a day but that
also entails you catching the meme at
its infant stage knowing that it's gonna
get bigger beginning the process of
making something based off that meme and
that's impossible to do that's like at
that point you have to like you have to
admit that you're gonna have one success
every like yeah
six months I was very surprised when the
anime fitted spinners video did as well
as it did so let's go we're just going
back to the weirdness thing of like
something that is so dumb and weird and
like so no one would ever make ya know
that's kind of what it is although is
that it turns out someone else made an
anime feature it's been her video to
like a month before yeah it's right it's
just like oh oh behind the curve again
yeah yeah I thought that was that was an
interesting spirit it was experience are
we doing on time Jarrett I don't have a
watch okay well I guess we're just gonna
cut off right now no um I just cuz I
realized that I have no way to track
time in here I should probably do that
yeah well she's like a big timer a clock
just a clock yeah it's really you know
the clocks are cheap these days you can
really just get a clock oh wow what a
clocks calm like my other sponsored
clocks yeah man I know that's funny cool
well it's been good talking and get
chatting
yeah having some fun I'm really glad we
have to catch up because after having a
kid I don't go anymore
I I work all day and then I go home and
I basically at all night I dad all night
and it's great but uh it's it's it's sad
man it's it's a it's a little it is a
little sad but it's it's also great it's
but it's also it's it's it's also a time
it's a very specific point in my life to
it's important you know you got to focus
on being a good dad and that's cool yeah
expectable yeah it's like we're in that
difficult stage to know he's so young
where you got to be there anyways yeah
so that's been good catching up like
personally well thanks for coming on
onboard here thank you for having me
buddy
cool all right guys well thanks for
listening to this awesome podcast if you
want to support it head on over to
quarto Digital dot store and get
yourself some swag it's really really
good stuff high-quality that's ever core
digital sword it's really really good
stuff it's great stuff honestly it's
it's I I am proud of it actually I'm
100m proud and Mike I'll hook you up
with some some dope samples if you want
hell yeah cool all right
good night peace love you